[موسيقى]
انطلقت فعاليات مهرجان درب لوسيل الذي يعد
احدث ممشا ووجهه ترفيهيه وسياحيه في قطر
المهرجان يحتفي بثقافات الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا وجنوب اسيا وسوف تخصص كل
ليله من ليالي المهرجان لاحدى الثقافات
حتى الخامس من نوفمبر
[موسيقى]
الارض والمشاريع لانجاح مثل هذه الفعاليات
وصلنا نحنا مقبلين على كاس العالم حاليا
دوله قطر على خارطه العالم
كما يتضمن المهرجان في كل ليله فعاليات
وعروض مذهله لطائرات الدرون وحفلات
موسيقيه وغنائيه
[موسيقى]
وان شاء الله العالم كله رح يشوف وخصوص
العالم الاوروبي والاجنبي هيشوفها دوله
قطر دوله عربيه كيف عم بتقدم وكيف عم تعمل
نسخه كثير حلوه من كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
وخلال مده البطوله سيكون هناك العديد من
العروض الثقافيه المحليه والعالميه هذا
فضلا عما يزيد على 600 فرقه فنيه من انحاء
العالم
مع قرب انطلاق كاس العالم بدات تشهد
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه ومنها دربلو سيل
احتفالات ثقافيه وفنيه يمكن للمر بها ان
يعيش اجواء البطوله الحماسيه والترفيهيه
من الان وطيله ايام البطوله ساره رشيد
الجزيره الدوحه